m
et bien bonjour et bienvenue sur
diagonale spécial shop boys band games
pour cette dixième partie bonsoir
stéphane bonsoir eloi incroyable
vraiment incroyable enfin moi j'arrive
toujours pas à le croire aujourd'hui
kasparov a de nouveau chuté et on a été
un peu surpris d'ailleurs par la fin
puisque on s'attendait pas à ce qu'il
abandonne aussi vite
on s'y attendait pas forcément mais en
tout cas sa position était bel et bien
perdante
et aujourd'hui ça nous aura appris à
cram dit que 25 ou et trois heures de
jeu pour réussir à battre l'imbattable
garry kasparov incroyable ce qui est
arrivé aujourd'hui
kasparov de nouveau mis en difficulté
par crown et dans une ouverture
surprenante on va dire en class40
n'arrive toujours pas à trouver les
coûts et d'une façon linéaire finalement
kramnik met la pression sur kasparov et
il finit par faire une gaffe
oui alors ce qu'on peut dire c'est
effectivement que crâne dit qu'ils
étaient mieux préparés que garry
kasparov ça s'est vu au niveau des temps
de réflexion puisque très vite kasparov
a pris 40 minutes de retard et ensuite
thermique est un petit peu mieux mais là
on ne voyait plus ce qui se passe et
stéphane on ne comprenait plus on
pensait que ça allait être nulle d'un
instant à l'autre quand tout à coup
l'incroyable s'est produit l'incroyable
l'incroyable c'est la cagade de garry
kasparov la cagade mais je sais pas mais
c'est très curieuse qui s'est passé on
croyait que kaka sport faut il continuer
à lutter pour la nulle sans trop de
difficulté d'ailleurs on pensait même
que c'était probablement nulle la partie
et puis non en trois coups pour les non
mais c'était vraiment vraiment
fantastique cette partie donc superbe
partie de l'année mercredi comme
stéphane il a vraiment bien joué
le rouleau compresseur leurs débuts dans
l'ouverture il ya mis la pression et
ensuite il y là il accomplit facilement
elle tout à fait il semblerait que
kasparov et raté tout simplement un coup
d'ouverture il aurait dû échanger son
fou contre les cavaliers
on va voir ça tout à l'heure de
l'analyse de la partie et il n'a pas
fait il a raté la chronique lui a laissé
aucune chance il a continué à augmenter
son avantage attaque ça semblait passé
et puis en fait on trouvait pas on
trouvait pas le coût des blancs trouvait
pas comment les blancs pouvaient
continuer la partie pour avancer mais
moi je n'arrive toujours pas y croire
mais ce que je sais sur le stéphane très
ému je suis sur ce chaos incroyable
et là on voit des images là de de la fin
de la partie des casseurs n'ont plus ils
croient pas remis sa montre
là il attend que kramnik viennent à
table est là il se rend compte mais on
ne sait pas on ne sait pas en fait qu'il
n'a pas vu kasparov ça a l'air d'être
une gare vraiment trivial
ah non il n'a pas compris là il n'a pas
compris il s'est dit merde ça y est je
suis dans la boîte il
il va mener 2 0 et ça c'était ça c'est
très dur parce que il reste six parties
kasparov et mené 2 0 et on voit pas
toujours pas comment il peut poser des
problèmes chroniques il n'a pas vraiment
réussi pour l'instant un chronique
rigole un écrit goal kasparov pleurs
voilà le résumé de ces images qu'on voit
ici quand nick est pas là il revient pas
quand l'équipe
il est détendu il sait que sa position
gagnante kasparov lui complètement ko
voilà on va le voir bientôt il va dans
un premier de la loire était là prêt à
vivre là ils arrêtent la pendule de la
et ilsinho la feuille capitulation de
garry kasparov alors chronique revient
voilà on se serre la main et 90 j'ai pas
vu on sait pas quoi on ne sait pas ce
que kasparov a raté tranquille et sans
doute ramenés que l'expliquent ramener
les deux toute façon on sait qu'en
sortir c'est quand la dernière fois où
chronique peut expliquer aussi à
l'étranger qu'il explique en fait c'est
clair kramnik expliquer ce gaz par an ce
qui l'a raté incroyable
on assiste peut-être eloi moment
historique changement de champion du
monde
est-ce que chronique va devenir le 14e
champion du monde de la lignée des
grands champions du monde c'est à dire
de ceux qui font les grands matches et
ça c'est la question qui reste posée
puisque c'est pas encore fini kasparov
peut encore revenir ce serait incroyable
ça dans un premier temps on va quand
même regarder cette partie avant de
tirer des conclusions à tirer les
conclusions pour voir déjà ne serait-ce
que comment garry kasparov s'est fait
pulvériser par l'animal cramique parce
qu'il faut bien le dire 25 ou trois
heures de jeu c'est quand même assez cas
au premier rang si quasiment une
miniature revélois assez une médiation
ce qui s'appelle miniature c'est ce
qu'on appelle une dictature on va voir
tout ça la partie voilà avec le choix
déjà de de kasparov qui revient à la
défense milinovic qui lui avait bien
réussi samedi puisqu'il avait posé de
gros gros problème chronique
à noter qu'on attende éventuellement qui
avaient des f3 chez krt à munich mais
non cramique relooker ses 3 et surtout
b4 une fois de plus c'est très important
dans ce match
ses chroniques qui dévie en premier
maintenant oui il joue pas là il avait
joué dans ces deux derniers
2 est une possibilité il choisit une
autre variante à noter que c'est la même
variante qui avait coûté à kasparov sa
première défaite depuis longtemps
l'année dernière contre sokolov donc
résonnent des fêtes d'ailleurs il
semblerait que kasparov ne comprennent
pas cette position incroyable mais enfin
on l'a déjà dit casse-pot n'a pas un
style vraiment universel alors que
cramique en revanche oui quand il peut
jouer toutes les positions à
différemment il maîtrise tous très bien
et là effectivement petit problème garry
kasparov dans ce type de structure dont
on va rappeler les enjeux
c'est effectivement les noirs veulent
sortir toutes leurs pièces tenir le
centre et ensuite éventuellement jouer
avec f3 ou en tout cas chasser le fourbe
et 4 bref les noirs les blancs
s'installe au centre et veulent
repousser les pièces noires tout ça
reste un petit rock de kasparov c'est
logique fou détroit tranquille en
passant les pièces la d5 contre attaque
au sein de ces logiques aussi c'est très
logique
à noter qu'on peut jouer de temps en
temps fou prend ces trois pour affaiblir
la structure mais c'est pas très
recommandé les blancs reprenant du pion
b et ensuite le phocéen trouvons un très
beau très beau poste sur les cases à 3
éventuellement
voilà donc un peu les les handicaps de
jeu le français 3 donc aux castors
ajouté 5
on est dans la grande variante de la
ninja beach valente rubinstein cavalière
3 le cou à la mode ces cas et j'ai eu
deux mécaniques revient aux classiques
c'est le coût qui avait permis à sokolov
de battre kasparov
si on ne dit pas de bêtise évidemment
ouais c'est 5 petit rock tout ça c'est
très classique si siné mais je crois que
les anglais l'ancien nom qu'on se trompe
pas les anglais en dioxyde donc c'est
une bonne nouvelle
le québec 8 normalement vient sur la
casse et 6 avec une position à peu près
symétrique est sur le coup des blancs a2
a3 et bien on prendra en c3 ça c'est la
grande variante c'est celle de zurich 53
le fameux tournoi le plus grand de
l'histoire
tout le monde joue et ça à l'époque
bronstein avait reback verbeek qui
arbitrent ici d'ailleurs
ouais tous les grands champions ont joué
cette position qui a et c 6 à 3 français
3 mai kasparov lui ici jousse et prend
des quatre grosses surprises oui petit
sur twin sector surprise puisque après
eux prend des quatre pions français caf
vous pensé quand il donne à croire qu
encore une fois le pion isolé qu'il
avait posé de gros problèmes
dans la partie de la semaine dernière il
c'est pire que ça stéphane puisque la
semaine dernière chronique y avait un
pion sur la casa 4 l'option était passé
de à 2 à 4 ans un petit affaiblissement
ce qui est un énorme affaiblissement
notamment de la case des 4 effectivement
même même avec le pion aux mal-classés
cram dit qu'ils avaient posé des
problèmes à caspar fille si c'est pas
tout à fait pareil mais il ya quand même
un tueur isolé
quel sport snobé 6 sort ses pièces c'est
très logique on veut jouer son fou sur
la case bessette puisque ce fou est
bouchée par le pion aux six se fout
c'est vite la ne peut pas sortir de ce
côté puisque le pion aux six le bouchon
qui va venir se poster sur la case
bessette ennuis de ce combat si ce qu'on
lit on joue souvent le pion b trop tôt
contrôle contrecoeur isolé puisque ce
pion v6 empêche la dame des huit de
sortir d'une des marques est bloqué la
dame des beats ne peut plus aller sur la
case b6 et puis le cavalier b8 on va
voir leur foi qui sera en 17
loin des bras blague non plus galles et
voilà tout ça fait beaucoup de flèches
mais des six avantages s'asseoir le
fourbe et cet inconvénient ça resserre
la position des noirs exactement où j'ai
cinq chroniques alors lui il met les
pièces partout voilà gros espace gros
espace pour les blancs gros avantage des
espaces fourbe et cette logique sur le
fou tours 1 alors je pense que c'est à
ce moment là que kasparov a dit qu'il
aurait dû prononcer trois oui mais c'est
très bizarre on n'a pas tout compris
puisque la conférence de presse kasparov
était complètement ko donc je vous
invite évidemment à revoir cette
conférence de presse dans les archives
il était ko tout simplement il a dit joe
du jeu fou prend ces trois mais il n'en
a pas dit beaucoup plus
voilà là il faut peut-être que lang
semble-t-il que les noirs prennent le
cavalier c3 à la place de quoi kasparov
ou le coup cavalia bessette et la
chronique nous surprendre tous les deux
voiliers en fait si ça se trouve c'est
le coût qui explique pourquoi il fallait
prendre en c3 pas tout à fait stéphane
dans un premier temps il choisit a eu
pour ses seins il ya d'abord une tour
sébastien qui défend le cavalier c3
s'est elle fait maintenant on peut
éventuellement envisager de le reprendre
avec la tour bat déjà voilà dans l'oeuf
est trop tard pour les noirs c'est
audrey pour en permettre alors pourquoi
la prise de bateaux aussi redoutable et
bien parce que la tour un chemin après
direct vers le roi noir ça c'est un
problème pour garry kasparov il ne veut
pas se faire attaquer il va pas sur tout
le tour s'est vite très logique et la
chronique jouer un coup effectivement
qui nous a surpris qui nous a surpris
mais qui finissent inverse puisqu'on
avait mentionné nous alors pendant le
direct les coups fourrés 3 ou fou
détroit qui semblait assez logique avec
deux clans différents mécanique lui a
trouvé mieux il ajouté mme b 3 pose la
question au foot des quatre voilà
attaque le fou
et créent une batterie avec le fou ces
quatre dames est fou attaque le pion aux
six n'a pas de le prendre mais l'asvel
bram et 27 mai les versions voilà ça met
la pression quand même et sa menace des
sacrifices peut-être peut-être ici
vraisemblablement garry kasparov aurait
dû jouer le kung fu prend ces trois
quand même mais vous pensez 3 et puis
ici deux possibilités soit en train de
la tour solution pas simplement prendre
la tour avec une petite initiative quand
même pour les blancs oui c'était un
homme d'âge oil on ait pris un fou à
noter maintenant qu'on aurait pu
envisager de remplacer sous de f4 sur
les cases suffisait un peu la casse des
sites visés beaucoup de cases c'est
kasparov ne voulait pas donner la paire
de les noirs peuvent aussi prendre le
cavalier en f3 et prendre le plan des
quatre ans suite à non ils peuvent pas
non ils peuvent pas peuvent pas non ici
ben en fait ça aurait fait l'habituel g
league prend le foot kasparov
oui kasparov s'est dit j'en ai marre
vainement après d'aylmer je garde les
fous je garde mon fou je le mets en
recettes
ouais et c'est là que c'est beau alors
c'est là que c'est vraiment incroyable
ce qui s'est passé oui s'il faudra mener
qui a joué un coup complètement
inattendue alors parce qu'on sait que
quand on a un pion isolé il ya plusieurs
possibilités soit on attaque le roi soit
plus le pion isolés sont de plus en plus
isolé soir mais ses cavaliers sur les
cases de cinq essais 5 mai lors être pas
parce qu'elle plombe et 6 mai la
chronique jouer un coup complètement
inattendu parce qu'il faut garder un
maximum de pièces tout à fait valable
alors c'est ça le truc c'est que en fait
on sait ce qu'il faut faire c'est qu'il
faut soit essayé d'attaquer le roi dans
quelque 2 500 moyen de l'attaqué soit
avancé le cas isolé pour l'échanger mais
en tout cas il ne faut jamais échangé
deux pièces mineurs çà c'est une règle
puisque évidemment ça allège la tension
pas énorme et crame dit qu'ici a vu plus
loin il avait plus subtile il joue le
couffo praxis surprenant très surprenant
alors vraiment inattendu enfin on
l'avait prévu quand même puisque c'est
le coût proposé par l'ordinateur
ouais dans cette position avec plusieurs
idées alors la première garry kasparov a
repris du cavalier donc ça devrait le
voir imaginons qu'il reprenne du fou
imaginons fou prend ainsi ce qui est une
autre possibilité est bien ici stéphane
il ya le coup qu'elle et ses 3 sur la
caisse des cinq probablement reste plus
qu'à valider cinq qui attaquent le plus
ancien et qu'il menace d'installer un
cavalier sur la case des six voilà
attaquant le fou en baisse est
effectivement et menaçant de d'installer
le deuxième cavaliers sur la case de 5
avec une très forte initiative va là on
peut envisager ici par exemple tours à
huit qui part toutes les menaces
mais il y a le court qu'avait lieu de
cinq avec une très belle initiative pour
les blancs puisque on menace simplement
de s'installer sur la caisse des six
on laisse beaucoup de choses et si les
noirs prénom à 5 et bien reprend du pied
en installant donc un poste un avant
poste en d6 extrêmement fort donc ici
problème pour garry kasparov
en tout cas il n'a pas aimé et après
vous progressez s'il s'est dit de toute
façon j'ai tout vu il réfléchit bien
longtemps là il sait bien qu'on
s'entraîne oui il prend du cavalier
exactement
alors on dit a priori c'est le coup
parfait point l'a aidé à sable un de la
casse des cinq maintenant toutes les
pièces noires contrôler le fou le
cavalier l'option et la dame et la dame
des huit mois se dit c'est bon mais
évidemment il ya quand même quelque
chose
l'idée la tête de crouch travail afin de
prouver si fantastique fantastic
sacrifice de kramnik même si on pouvait
le prévoir ce moment de la partie il
fallait que kramnik le voit quand ils
jouent dame b 3 vous êtes donc il a
fallu que cranie pour ce sacrifice à
noter que c'est quand même ça tu vises
thématiques dans ce type d'ouverture
puisque la tour e 1 rajoute de la
pression sur la colonne e et le fawcett
n'est pas défendu c'est vrai c'est
totalement thématiques en tout cas ici
c'est clairement une préparation maison
de vladimir kramnik effectivement il a
joué ça tellement vite que ça venait de
son laboratoire personnel pour la
première fois kramnik vraiment sort une
grosse nouveauté est l'ouverture
grosse nouveauté sera ku'damm détroit
qui n'a l'air de rien donc à leur
expliquons quand même ce qui se passe
e.on a pris en 6 on attaque la tour
s'est vite donc ici obliger les noirs
doivent prendre
ouais il faut prendre déjà puis sinon
les blancs aux 20 pions pour rien les
noirs et les blancs reprennent ils ont
gagné une pièce d'un printemps l'instant
les noirs et les blancs et noirs devant
la halle nord en gagner une pièce quand
même pour les pions alors surtout rev7
mais les tables la défense puisque là on
fait chacun en attaque le font en même
temps voilà le coup parfait salaires des
taux à 7 qui protège le fou mais mais
mais la tour est cloué et on joue
simplement le coup cavaliers angers 5 et
c'est terminé s'est terminée puisque la
seule défense pour défendre la tour
c'est de jouer dans les suites et là
tout simplement on prend la tour on
prend le taureau et après d'apprendre
cavaliers tout simplement récupère le
fou avec une vieille idée plus une
qualité de plus tout ce qui est en plus
il peu d'options quand la qualité à
l'opium c'est énorme c'est énorme c'est
complètement wintour et d'apurement
sélective terminé c'est terminé donc
après d'un point à 6 garry kasparov lui
a calculé la il a commencé à jouer très
vite ils joueront en fuite
ouais normal kramnik prend aux 7 est
maintenant là contrepoint de petrov
c'est qu'il prend le cavaliere 3 voilà
ça casse la structure des pions blancs
et diagramme n'est que simplement si tu
reprends je fais dam des huit
professions des 4 et ton roi va être
plus faible que le mien puisque tu auras
des pions cassé je vais dans les cahiers
pour attaquer alors la chronique peut
échanger les dames
peut se dire chronique effectivement je
vais changer les dab c'est une
possibilité
voilà sur quoi kasparov ont repris il a
tellement progressé 3 on prend avec 3 et
la tour reprend avec une finale où les
noms rampillon - mais la structure des
pions blancs fait que c'est probablement
une finale ou que les normes vont
arriver à tenir effectivement pourquoi
simplement parce que à gauche on
adoption contre 2 donc ça ce n'est pas
un avantage et à droite trois pions
effectivement contre 2 mais ils sont
tellement mauvais ces trois pions
tellement dispersé que ça permet pas du
tout d'avancé donc à ce moment fort
effet nul facile ici probablement donc
travnik après réflexion sur fou pour un
f3 prend un risque
il prend un risque enfin le risque parce
qu'il est sans voix faible il joue géant
prend fou et si les noirs aux mêmes
échanges les dames et il le pian des
quatre au centre va faire la différence
se fera de plus en plus ça fera de
vendre plus donc il faut absolument que
les gens reprennent le pion des quatre
ça laisse la dame blanche l'attaquent
finalement c'est dire qu'en fait
cramique dit oui à une attaque pour les
noirs peut-être mais moi j'ai une
attaque encore plus forte
il a des attaques encore plus forte
alain kasparov ici commence un peu à
douter il s'est dit il avait pas
vraiment vu ça surtout le coup de massue
chronique ce 19e concave à libé 5
alors attention né au 19e coup donc dans
six coups c'est terminé regardez bien
cette position et dites vous que dans
six coups garry kasparov champion du
monde depuis 15 ans qui a les noirs
n'arrive pas à tenir alors que là on
voyait toujours pas comment les blancs
pouvaient
nouveau commentaire envoyé pas c'est à
dire que la position est tellement
proche d'une simplification générale il
ya de moins en moins de pièces sur
l'échiquier il va y avoir des taux qui
vont s'échanger tout de suite qu'on se
demande ce qui va se passer
alors évidemment l'idée de vladimir
kramnik il vient de jouer qui avait dit
b5 pour l'instant tout a été à peu près
forcé depuis ce coup faut point m6 oui
ça tacle dames savent que le calme
revienne sur la case des six lequel ils
s'insinuent ont décider s'il fera d
échec au roi qui semble dangereux
éventuellement l'afsset met enfin la
position d'europe kasparov avait l'air
solide d'autant plus qu'ici gary très
tranquillement d'impression des deux
était la nature
pénard récupération égalité matérielle
donc ouais et a priori on ne voit pas ce
qui se passe là la tour cn est attaqué
il faut que kramnik échange des tours
c'est ce qui fait à noter quand même une
petite variante c'était femmes
si on essaie de jouer les caïds et six
dans cette position c'est possible et
bien c'est réfutée par le coup donc
surtout concerné dame prend la fuite et
qui vend il faut jouer dans le français
a en fait tout simplement simplement et
après tourcoing dames on joue tout
reprend mais cette fois-ci et chats
coraux et je suis pour moi que les
blancs ne peuvent pas prendre la fuite
roger 2 et maintenant il faut re recalés
tout ça tourabi tu es là on a deux tours
pour la dame
c'est à dire c'est un avantage si les
blancs n'ont pas de matty médias c'est
pas bon pour les noirs c'est pas très
bon tout simplement pour les blancs
c'est pas très bon pour les blancs
voient donc ici cramique ne peut pas
jouer ça après dun prend b2 il joue donc
très logiquement tour pro tour tant
qu'un tour les regrets voilà est là et
cavaliers des 6 et 10 6 à l'est de la
vallée se rapproche du haut adour en
noir attaque la tour s'est vite et
menaces probablement de refaire des
échecs qui peuvent être dangereux mais
on voyait pas vous ne voyez pas du tout
ne voyez pas de suite 20 gagnants il y
avait beaucoup d'échecs possible mais
pour les blancs ont envoyé au moins là
nul mais on voyait pas d' attaques
gagnantes la casse fin juin cool qui a
l'air pas mal finalement
il aurait pu tout aura huit tours b 8 il
choisit tomber 8 c'est à dire qu'il est
que d'occase en fait garry kasparov qui
n'ont pas l'air très emballante
oui parce que les autres cases de la
tour sont pas bonnes si la toux revient
sur la casse g8 autre case possible ou
la tour n'est pas en prison
et bien tout de suite c'est matt à cause
de cavaliers qui vient sur la case f7
ici le fameux match stéphane d'y aller
tous à l'étouffée puisque le roi noir ne
peut pas sortir il est pris par ses
propres pièces plus par ses propres
pièces donc le cavaly faisant échec
on ne peut pas supprimer de cavaliers il
n'y a pas de solution donc il faut que
la tour joue sur une des cases pointé en
verre ici
et quelle forme on choisit la kazembe
évite les sens répond à cette emprise en
fait il veut il veut que kramnik perdre
du temps et de l'attention à prendre ce
pion à 7 en fait une sorte de piège
parce que la tour soit on habite où on
débite ça change pas grand chose
ça change pas grand chose on n'a pas vu
de vendre concrètes ou en tout cas la
torah 8 aurait été mal placé ici
kasparov donne une option supplémentaire
à kramix et donc peut-être un peu de
l'intox
il s cramique jouer dame prend pion à 7
évidemment après le coup des noirs qui
seraient vraies sont entourés fuite
parce qu'il ya pas trop de casse pour
cette tournée pas trop brutale les
blancs peuvent revenir en cette voie là
mais la casse ford joue peut-être tours
à huit et la 14e retour à huit
attaquants purs à deux ayant aidé à tour
sur sa sur cette colonne là on ne voit
pas trop la pointe
à vrai dire oui la seule chose qu'on a
vu c'est que travnik n'a pas pris pions
qu'il a préféré quelque chose de plus
direct
wen tout à fait convaincre la chronique
joue sur tourbe et vite très vite
joliette cet échec échec voilà j'ai vite
fait friser voilà et la petit coup de
kramnik dames 6 2 me 6 et voilà c'est
pas mal parce que la dame si sa menace
de la taille et tout fait et tout fait
encore une fois mais imaginons que les
noirs jouent le coutour à 8
donc il ne sert à rien tout va vite
c'est une bien la menace des chroniques
voit on voit tout de suite que c'est ces
cavaliers h6 échec au roi échec double
sas et thématiques donc je vous invite à
bien regarder ce qui se passe
les deux pièces font échec ouais
première possibilité le roi vient en
aide suite si l'on revient inférieur ça
c'est éliminer vitré il y adam eve sept
matches voilà exactement
donc ça c'est clair c'est très simple et
de l'unpol est compliqué elle revient
sur la 15 h 8 donc là on se dit qu'est
ce qui se passe et la très jolie
je crains bien joué le coup si on
revient à f7 ça fait ça finisse le fait
nul mais il ya mieux
on joue dame âgée 8 échec échec et la
dame est protégé par le cavaliere si ça
c'est très joli
la dame est protégé donc le roi est là
ne peut pas prendre la dame vous voyez
voilà ne peut pas le faire donc il faut
enfermer son roi donc il faut prendre
avec une autre pièce sur la tour sur le
cavalier supposons que la tour prennent
voilà et maintenant ça y est on a créé
la boîte plus qu à l'étouffée dedans il
ya plus qu'à revenir en effet il y était
encore à matha l'étouffer une fois de
plus c'est le matin à l'étouffée donc
thèmes récurrents ici mais là ils
forçaient la vidéo est alors ils étaient
amenés par les noirs mais là il est
forcé par les blancs donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut pas jouer un coup anodin dans
cette position il y avait une
possibilité intéressante évidemment là
c'est là que kasparov et la faute
on peut je sais pas si on montre la
faute d'abord de kasparov qui perd ou si
on montre d'abord le bon coup mais bon
ton d'avoir le bon coup montrons d'abord
le beaucoup voilà h5 c'était le bon âge
c'est un coup à toi alors h67 en interne
on va regarder h12 d'abord 5
quelle est l'idée est bien évidemment
maintenant sur cavani h 6 échecs et donc
on ne va plus enfermer dans la suite on
repart en acheter oui vous savez il ya
de l'air pour le roi voilà n'y a plus de
boîte on a créé de l'air voilà ici
kramnik aurait sûrement joué cavalier
gissinger chef et cheikh rage suite et
forcée voilà alors suroît et 8 et de 9,7
mat
voilà on l'a déjà dit et maintenant le
bon coup le joli coup dans sa position
c'est dans les cinq dames f5 superbe
voilà quelle est l'idée est bien on
laisse passer la tour stéphane on
protège le roi blanc ou passage cercle
et noir ne peuvent plus faire des
chèques perpétuelle ça va être dur peut
faire un excellent sur la colonne jeou
et le roi blanc les pièces blanches
contrôle très bien tout ça dames et
cavaliers sont en attaque et en défense
et à kehl en france voilà par exemple si
les noirs jouent tour 8es bien en
échange des tours cavaliers pro tour et
à la fin d'un match 7 matches tout à
fait donc ça ce n'est pas possible
la menace c'est aussi ce bref donc il ya
un couple slip c'est le coût d'un point
à 2 stéphane prend 1,2 sur quoi on joue
tous rocistes sa menace maintenant tout
reprend ainsi son volumineux ou grands
cavaliers alors là peut-être d'avoir
pour les dames tour baisse est tombée
cet ici oui alors non puisqu'il y aurait
à willy à leur tour bessette c'est un
coup intéressant il est tombé cette ça
permet aussi à cause de tout reprend et
non ça marche pas tomber cette aurait
été possible à l'annoncé saïda tour
invité chacun à victor huit échecs
voyant plus loin
le cavalier doit prendre la tour c'est
obligé voilà et la dame est dommage cet
échec et mat la machette échec et
matériaux non c'est parce que je la
magie cet échec et mat
voilà c'est terminé mais c'est terminé
il faut prendre la tour et il y avait
des risques seront terminés et oui donc
on peut pas empêcher tout reprendre six
grosses menaces quoi alors si on peut
l'empêcher on a le ku'damm des 5 propose
en échange des dames celle là c'est la
position vraiment clé de cette partie
après d'amd 5 donc évidemment il y est
ce qu'on peut pas revenir en défense du
cavaliere 6 non non plus à tour problème
6 menace d'un match 7 matches iliad md5
ainsi être stéphane un instant l'idée le
courage et vite
bon j'avais droit j'ai vite mais tout à
fait
moi j'évite maintenant si on prend six
il y à damas un échec très subtil et
dame revient tant de la toile voilà ça
c'est un problème donc ici le très bon
coup pour les blancs s'est approché
d'eux en voudront cette langue parce qu
ils ont l éclairage et deux rouges et
deux et là dedans dames 1 d'un bep 2 bat
maintenant je ne sais plus trop quoi
proposer puisqu'il est plein de menaces
donc le coût normal ces dames des cinq
cherche en échange des dames et après
tourcoing 9,6 et on peut pas reprendre
la cour en la reprendre la tour dames
trois dames on peut pas reprendre la
tour avec le pion non plus parce que la
dame est en prison oui mais d'ailleurs
faut peut-être pas mettre une femme en
bref d'accord alors ça c'est une rare
critique c'est le vin les statiques est
ce que les blancs avec leurs cavaliers
peuvent à réaliser c'est en noir
voilà c'est ça toute cette pression ça
se résume à ça ça aurait dû être joué je
pense est ici tous enfin tous les
analystes ont l'air d'accord
le cavalier va revenir angers 5 en d2 et
en b1 pour remplacer le riche en
avancées a priori ce cavalier arrêterait
les pions sont des femmes ouais mais bon
évidemment ça demande plus d' analyse là
on est en direct très peu de temps après
la partie on n'a pas le temps de vous
faire ça il va y avoir des analyses de
fou sur internet sur ses téléphones
cellulaires c'est une très très grosse
partie this way donc bref dans cette
position il fallait jouer le coup h5
progrès avec la barre entre cosne a
mentionné qu'il est complexe
autre possibilité c'était de quoi
acheter skype a l'air génial non plus
mais kasparov craque et jouent tour à
fuite - touré suite qui empêche
complique cagade alors il n'y a pas de
maths à l'étouffée parce qu'en fait sur
cavaliers h 6 échecs rush et roger vite
sur dame g8 et des empreintes du
cavalier et latour contrôler la case s
est ensuite voilà sur dame j'ai vite il
n'y a qu'avec des programmes
voilà est pas tout puisque si tourcoing
damian maths à l'étouffée mais lacazette
la knesset et contrôler mes chroniques a
vu plus loin il a vu une petite pointe
il joue cavalier des huit échecs sur
l'autre classe des huit échecs
le roi doit partir le roi doit partir il
le joue kasparov et la dame cette dame 7
et la tour et pas défendable la tour
n'est pas défendable alors qu'est ce qui
se passe effectivement sur tours j'ai
vite on ne commande plus il ya kelly à
vii maths à l'étouffée maths à
l'étouffée et donc kasparov ça aurait
été obligé s'il est voulu continuer
parce que surtout réduite
il y a d'impro 8 sur tours 8 k takada
m'en prends tout simplement parce qu'il
ya le mc du couloir cette fois là il
peut démarrer grâce par wifi
tous les modes de cette partie c'est une
thématique c'est horrible le mât du
couloir mais bref
ici il faudrait prendre ce cavalier
débite ses forces et exactement et après
d'âpres entourent échec au roi kg
mickaël j'habite là il ya le ku'damm des
cinq avec un gain technique alors
pourquoi ces gagnants ceux des femmes
très simplement compliqué c'est parce
que la tour en gros est beaucoup plus
forte que le cadenas
pourquoi parce qu'il ya des pions des
deux côtés à noter que la menace s'est
probablement pour 1,8
oui pas tout de suite pas tout de suite
mais bon on va trouver des menaces et
bref cette tour va tellement facilement
à gauche comme à droite
le cavalier est incapable de faire ça en
gros c'est bon effectivement c'est pas
évident à comprendre mais quand on est
bien entraîné et bien enfin ce qu'ils
savent c'est pour ça qu'on est là aussi
aujourd'hui c'est qu'en fait on
s'attendait que kasparov lutte
on est parti et non une lutte pas après
dams est il abandonne donc on n'a pas
droit à la finale technique justement
que karmique granik aurait sûrement
gagné n'était pas facile à gagner mais
au niveau de ses champions là c'est sûr
c'est gagner voilà mais nous mais il
faut qu'on voit faut qu'on vérifie il
faut qu'on joue la partie on peut
s'amuser d'ailleurs faire ça et sur
internet c'est ce que vont faire tous
les gens sûrs que tous les gens qui tous
les sites qui vont commenter ces partis
tous les sites internet vont commenter
toutes les variantes possibles donc si
on veut en savoir plus ce sera possible
de voir toutes ces analyses de tous les
grands maîtres du monde qui vont
analyser cette position alors ce qui est
sûr c'est que le sel la dernière qu'on
vous a montré avec la tour contre
cavaliers ne sera pas trop analyser tout
simplement parce que kasparov n'a pas
voulu la jouer parce qu'il sait qu'il
n'ya aucune ressource pour les noix les
il peut jouer des positions perdantes
mairie kasparov mais quand il ya des
complications possibles
là il n'y en a aucune c'est extrêmement
simple et puis évidemment kramnik en
face c'est pas n'importe qui c'est pas
le joueur à la joue et légère oui c'est
pas glorieux pulvérisé donc peut-être un
petit bilan comme de la situation après
dix parties stéphane je crois que
on est un peu car oui mais aussi et
c'est surtout kasparov quel chaos
kasparov idée très très mal
effectivement le score c'est 6 à 4 c'est
énorme fan 2 0 surtout deux victoires à
zéro il reste six parties il faut que
craint il faut que tu as part of en
gagner au moins 2 22 pour annuler le
match et conserver son titre
le problème c'est qu'il a trois fois les
nous les blancs et que pour l'instant il
a posé quasiment aucun problème à
kramnik grammy qui a eu aucun problème
avec les pièces noires il a joué sa
berlinoise sur les anglaises kasparov
était ridicule bref pour l'instant
kasparov n'a pas d'ouverture a joué
contre eux cramique et en plus quand ils
allaient noir kasparov il n'a pas
d'ouverture non plus il est complètement
pulvérisée dans ce match kasparov
pulvérisé il va jouer ses dernières
cartes
il faut qu'ils jouent je pense toutes
les parties y compris avec les blancs
mais aussi avec les noirs faut qu'ils
cherchent les complications a peut-être
enfin on va voir caspar aux jouets
l'estonienne alors enfin je ne sais pas
si on l'attend tant que ça mais ça peut
donner une partie par dont une partie
très intéressante les italiens en
général c'est explosif c'est vrai c'est
la folie non mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que à prévoir c'est du grand spectacle
puisque gary kasparov comme ça dos au
mur c'est de la dynamite
oui il a sauté il est prêt à exploser
c'est clair il va arriver comme un fou
en courant il va sortir de samy
limousine il va arriver très vite sur
l'échiquier mais il va commencer à jouer
hélas aucun doute je pense quand même
que garry kasparov à quelques surprises
en réserve
on ne peut pas l'enterrer comme ça
gagnent ce que possible donc à partir de
jeudi c'est certain
kasparov est dos au mur il est obligé
d'essayer de gagner à partir de jeudi
met à fond il faut qu'il joue c'est
parti à fond il faut qu'ils tentent le
tout pour le tout le problème c'est
qu'ils risquent de se tomber sur des
grosses préparations de chroniques
c'est ça le problème le prince et qui
ont pour l'instant il a il n'a rien
démontré donc moi je t'en reste à
prouver il a eu peur de préparation
kramnik c'est ça le problème maintenant
si là il a plus le choix il va plus
avoir peur il va être obligé de jouer
c'est chaud affaire à suivre donc on
vous donne rendez vous jeudi prochain
pour le direct à partir de 16h heure
française
merci d'avoir suivi ce diagonale spécial
brendan world championship et on vous
donne rendez vous jeudi 16h au revoir
oh
m